le cercle vertueux de la victoire et
l'obsession de tous les entraîneurs au
club de tennis de table de
voisins-le-bretonneux geoffrey nisand ne
connais pas ce problème
en l'espace d'une année ses joueuses
n'ont connu la défaite qu'à une seule
reprise face à rambouillet un bilan
quasi parfait accompagné de deux montées
successives historique qui ne leur donne
pas pour autant la grosse tête on
apprenait quand on a commencé on était
des matches et on en parlera encore on
reste les pieds sur terre
comerica miné l'équipe saint-quentinoise
est un parfait mélange d'expérience et
de jeunesse entre la capitaine salomé la
porte à 27 ans ancienne joueuse
d'elancourt habitué des championnats
nationaux et la précoce camille concerne
15 ans il y à 13 années et des dizaines
de match les filles de geoffrey nisand
joue dans le bon tempo
mais leur entraîneur se doit d'être de
plus en plus exigeants c'est partager
c'est à dire que oui on va au mode et
match en se disant ça va être facile on
va gagner mais c'est difficile dans le
sens où
il ya parfois un manque de motivation on
sait qu'on va aller faire un match où
les filles vont jouer sur des films en
forte
c'est difficile à gérer dans le sens où
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur non plus
d'où qu'on veut monter cette réussite
est symbolisée par bérengère les
surnommer la bûcheronne pour son jeu de
frappe en un an et demi elle a gagné
presque 500 points de classement et ce
succès l'équipe chinoise le construit
aussi en dehors du terrain une
complicité on rigole beaucoup on essaye
de faire des choses en dehors du tennis
de table ensemble après les matchs où
les week-ends donc ça me permet d'être
vraiment solidaire solidaire et joueuses
de l'entente voisin saint-arnoult
devront l'être pour se maintenir en
nationale 2 premier match à poitiers le
19 janvier